what is happening there reject nation we
are going to watch
part one finale of the bad batch titled
return to camino
a place where hunter told omega she
would never have to return
looks like he's going against that
promise today guys if you end up
enjoying our reaction please go ahead
hit that like button subscribe and click
that notification bell to get notified
when our reaction for the fab
actual finale is as always full length
watch logs where you sync up with the
time code for the bad match over our
patreon page covering a whole bunch of
shows over there as well we're at the
same tier you get the option for
highlights and full-length reaction
watch-alongs included
lastly pratham jindal is sexy mofo
you you keep being sexy with these edits
appreciate it bud anywho
let's watch this badass show
[Music]
where are we going you'll find out soon
enough
using my calm won't work they'll know
it's a trap
it's a trap easter egg
have me the spanx
that should do it
nearly finished getting the systems
online she wasn't too happy about it
what else
let's go get hunter
this is not going to go the way you
think
he's no longer on darrow what do you
mean
where is he kamino because that's what
we're returning to
coming home
where are the rest of them they'll be
here
so you're the one they call hunter the
destruction your squad caused on ryloth
got my attention got me aroused
i questioned the clone's motives with
this old squad
i don't trust any of them if his plan
fails none of them will be a problem any
longer
keep an eye on things yes
[Music]
activating hunter's calm was intentional
the empire wants us to come to camino
i'm uncertain as to why oh turn him back
now
trap here every platform down there will
be swarming with troopers
not this one trust me
i've got a bad feeling about this
we are at the given coordinates omega
there is nothing here
you have to get lower
i go any lower we will be in the water
scanners are picking up a large
structure directly beneath us
yeah here it go omega
way to go omega earn the team's trust
never doubted you for a second how are
we going to get into the city
we'll take the tube system
okay come on
omega how did you know this existed now
let's say
this tunnel leads to her private
research lab hmm
you uh all right it doesn't matter
saving hunter is what matters where are
all the rags
when did you start caring about them you
don't seem too concerned
why would i be because the empire will
be phasing out clones next
not the ones that matter
i think they're headier on that one
hunter
a ship was detected entering the system
but we lost them below scanner right
it's them don't bother they don't leave
their own behind
you tried to kill us we didn't have a
choice
and i did he just
confirm the theory that he chose this
path it's possible i mean it certainly
could be applied in those words
that looks like every other lab to me
hunter's calm is still active
i'll pinpoint his location i don't get
it
what's so special about this land it's
where i was created
you all were here too ah
mutations were enhanced in this room
unit 99 began right here i was there is
that true
how could i possibly know that there's
nothing in the system
anyone else think that's weird
do not shoot i am az345
omega i am relieved it is you what are
you doing down here
i am in hiding soldiers were
deactivating droids and forcing key
kamino and medical personnel onto
transport
those who resisted were eliminated all
clone troopers were reassigned and
transferred off world
with the exception of ct 9904
you must leave not without hunter found
him
his com is pinging
you're with us welcome to the team man
i've seen what the empire is doing you
still don't see the bigger picture
can't you see they're using you that
inhibited chip in your head
we have an unauthorized entry on
platform five time to go
oh i don't think it's the inherit huh
[Music]
those are not clone troopers they're tk
troopers
like on darrow hunter's on the move this
way
oh no
hunter is directly above us the training
room that's open ground precisely why we
will not be going in through the main
entrance like he would expect
and enter through the lift that should
give us a slight advantage
i think he's going to suspect that we
should stick together
oh that goes right cross has after us
not you
if things go south we'll send you a
signal get back to the ship and contact
rex
well guess you're wrong about that
together again you won't be needing your
weapons
oh
yeah you think we'd bring her here
we're smarter than that find the kid
it's the signal we should flee to the
research lab no
we have to help them
i have an idea are those dark troopers
[Music]
we're running out of time commander you
betrayed everything we stood for
were loyal to each other you weren't
loyal
to me i'm going to give you
what you never gave me
a chance
okay then
freeze i found the girl
send her on a shuttle off world cruiser
don't
it's for her own good you want to
protect the kid
and let her go stop pretending to be
something you're not hunter
we're not like the rakes we are superior
can't protect the galaxy without
strength
this is what we were made for
oh cool shot why would we trust you
stand down negative commander
[Laughter]
join the empire i
you're a hero it's time to stop running
join the empire you really don't get who
we are
don't make the same mistake twice
don't become my enemy
you never were oh
i feel so bad for this guy i know he
just wants
[Music]
a few too purpose droids i can see that
yeah come on omega
the depth of field on these shots
[Music]
oh look at it fighting alongside with
that damn
uh the hair on my chest is standing up
all remaining forces out let the clones
die together
[Music]
nice rep between the eyes
all essential personnel have been
removed from kamino
the cloning technology is now firmly
under imperial control
very good admiral you may fire when
ready
move into position
you're working
crosshair forget the empire this
isn't you it's your inhibitor chip
it's not yeah
wrong i had my chip removed
i believe in this all no
you knew it knew it yeah
since when does it matter
oh yeah this
is who i am
stunned yeah yeah
well that was that was confirmed
[Music]
oh [ __ ] it was hiding right in plain
sight this whole time
that is crazy
[Laughter]
love that what a great detail
you'll just have to talk him into it
post kidnapping you know brainwash him
back
sir we're in position open fire
[Music]
oh
oh jesus
[Music]
[Laughter]
part one very dark
yeah decent amount to unpack
all right before we get into it i want
to shout out to v84 for hitting me up on
instagram
getting me excited about watching this
episode tell me this one was so good
as much as this is not easily the
out of all the shows we've ever covered
this has got to be like the least viewed
one
for uh us on our end that we've ever had
however i appreciate those who keep
coming back to watch us
for for this one so people like to be
really do appreciate it thank you and
everyone who's here today
but uh yeah that was a hell of a part
one right there
cross hair theory confirmed that he
chose this and
i thought he divulged it at the very top
at least it seemed like it was an
indicator
or a clue when he's when they're talking
about choice and he's like and i did
and i was like wait is that a clue and
they keep saying it's the inhibited chip
it's inhibited
i'm like you're setting this up so much
in this episode to say that it's not the
inhibitor chip
and come to find out it wasn't and they
were building it up the whole time
because
crosshair clearly felt like uh
this is where he has purpose uh this is
where he
you know like what he was designed for
ultimately can be used to its fullest
potential
along with everyone else too were out as
fugitives or anything else that they
don't
that's not what they were built for so
it's just a guy who's like looking for
belonging
which is kind of like heartbreaking when
you think about it
because i loved the revelation of that
and i loved that the whole time it was
like oh man
it was right there but he just has those
scars
so you can't see the incision of when he
had the
the chip removed but yeah this was all
just a matter
a lot of us were thinking that it might
that might be the case and
sure enough it was i don't know if
i i have no idea what's going to happen
with him i feel like
beginning of the next episode he's back
on the team i changed my mind yeah i
slept on it
right i don't see that being the case
uh but i i love i love the show went
there with that it's something that a
lot of us were thinking they might be
doing and i love that they committed to
that choice
because it just makes the whole thing
feel a little bit more sinister and
complicated
and it just makes for better
storytelling as opposed to a repeat beat
of
it's the chip it's the chip it's the
chip it's so much harder it's so much
more dramatic and heartbreaking because
yeah i mean
this guy's just down for the imperial
cause and is also in a position where
like all the clone troopers are being
phased out and rear you know requis
reticent across the galaxy jettisoned
the but uh you know he is in this weird
unique position where he's one of the
few who is sort of
being given an opportunity in the new
empire and so
yeah i mean it plays into that sense of
you know
needing purpose that much further
because it's like
you see from the empire side every time
you cut back to rampart like you see how
much this guy probably
really isn't in crosshairs corner
whatsoever but also how crosshair could
be very
swayed towards that because of yeah that
sense of purpose and and
having you know spent so much time
fighting for you know
this yeah um yeah and then to bring it
back around where
yeah i feel like that's just the best
dramatic choice to make is where like
yeah it's a real
rift in the group and it's you know the
whole
question of what's going on in the
galaxy right now you know absolutely
well rampart doesn't care about him
they're willing to discard him just like
anyone else you know
and i thought it was interesting to have
the
the the emotional aspect of crosshair
thinking that he was betrayed by his
brothers
i guess that's what was making me feel
pitiful towards him was that
he seemed he was very no he was direct
about it he said you guys betrayed me
yeah and it makes it brings you back to
that first episode of this season
where it was mainly cross hair and
hunter who were
butting heads the whole time about what
is the right choice to do
and while you're totally on hunter's
side
for all of this he really wasn't ever
hearing cross hair out
yeah you know he wasn't having a
discussion it was like no we're doing
this i'm the leader we're doing this
yeah you know not that not that hunter
ever came across like a bad dude
by any stretch and nor did i ever go
wait a minute hunter let's hear lacrosse
you should follow the orders but in
terms of
looking at the perspective and kind of
flashing back to some scenes in my own
head it's interesting having
that later to it because when you're
first watching the episode you're like
it's the [ __ ] it's the chip it's the
damn chip that's all it is
you know but as the show was progressing
you're going it's not the chip i don't
think it's a chip
it does it seems to really be dedicated
to this yeah that was cool it was a cool
step
and uh and a really neat cliffhanger
it's crazy didn't realize how much i
care about those camino labs until now
yeah get that montage at the end of like
all the empty spaces and you're like oh
we're never gonna get to come back here
dude i'm gonna miss this dark desolate
planet
messed up researchers messed all this
heavy rain
thunder all the time the aesthetic well
that's the thing too is like the
aesthetics were gorgeous across this
with all the water and rain elements and
then the contrast with the light
and like the really specific like
especially towards the end when they're
starting to fire on the city and
everything like
the depth of field and some of those
shots like they really did a great job
with the scale and the scope and really
making it feel
you know appropriately huge you know
for every situation they're having to
deal with like i really felt the tension
across this episode i was
i was caught up in the just sort of like
yeah
time bomb of it all totally was
when you start seeing like the empty
halls and the transition and
when you're coming from clone wars and
prequels and you see
where camino is very is
it's a very busy and it's such a
vital part and there is something like
not that i really
cared about nala say or the prime
minister
the actual kaminoans in particular like
did i really
care about them not really but they were
such an inhabitant part of the world
here
and not that they appear in you know
anything after the prequels and then you
know
the shows and stuff there was something
that leaves you with this
hollow feeling hollow in the in the
right
dark desolate way in your own heart
because you feel the absence of all
these people yeah you could feel you
could feel the empire taking over in
this like goodbye
yeah and like the the overall
destruction and chaos at the end as as
uh
a terrible of a situation as it is you
can't help but admire the gorgeous
animation
of all this glorious mess that is to
behold here and
you know wherever they're going but i
think the tube situation
uh indicated that there's you know
probably some type of place to hide out
at
yeah um not just the the heli that the
the landing spot they went to but it
seemed like through the tube that there
were some like maybe like gungan stuff
there too yeah a little bit uh the tubes
kind of remind me of the empire strikes
back tubes that uh
lucas fell down after
you know the whole thing with darth
vader
yeah uh it reminded me of that
and you know when you're going to like
nala says facility
am i saying her name right i think i am
if you go to nala says facility
and learning what it's all about and how
she was taken last episode
she's got it because because you know
mandalorian season two they were doing
all this eluding towards the creation of
snoke
and uh like working with the cloning to
to bring back palpatine
and then that's kind of what they were
they're teasing here too
and so i'm wondering if there will be
some type of ultimate bridge here
with the story lines of bad batch amanda
lorien because i feel like nala say
she's got to be working on like
palpatine cloning or snoke yeah
thingy you know anything to prolong the
most valuable sith lords
it's like the clones are such a big part
of star wars and
uh there was there's been a couple
there's a lot of talk to me we were
following clones sure the batch
themselves
but there's there's a lot of like
mysterious aspects to the cloning that
have been taking place in this show too
like the episode with
um bane and fennick shand
when they're going toe to toe and they
and and omega discovers that facility
so yeah i don't know i i just can't be a
little curious there's something very
ominous about the whole
going to nala says facility and seeing
where the batch was born
yeah see i appreciate that plot thread
because it seems like you absolutely
could tie it into
cloning yeah snoke or or uh
sidious or any of those people or
palpatine i should say
but uh i can also see if they decide
not to maybe go with that because i
don't know like the
fleshing out snoke almost feels like
sort of a dead end
now just because of what happened but
then palpatine makes more
yeah palpatine makes the most sense but
i feel like you don't even necessarily
have to do that
like you easily can but there's a lot of
other stuff you can bring in because i
mean you know it's like it started with
these clone armies and then it goes you
know
theoretically perhaps through to that
but there's so many other sort of nasty
bio experiments and that also fits into
your you know nazi metaphor of the
empire
well also mandalorian um
i would say part one of the finale of
season two
even though it was just one episode but
the first half
also had the dark oh they were in the
last half too when luke was messing them
all over but uh
but the the dark troopers yeah right
it's the right word right i think
constantly i'm like is it death or dark
i think i think it's dark troopers right
uh
they have the dark troopers there too
but i believe they fought side by side
when they were
in the first episode here when they were
doing like the let's test out how good
this batch really is
yeah i think they had a couple of them
in there um
but yeah i don't know i'm seeing some
parallels here where they might be doing
that and there seems to be some riffing
on the here the star wars is very big on
hero's journey
and there seems to be some heroes
journey going alongside with the hunter
characters specifically of what they've
been implementing
and uh yeah it's like it's interesting
how they've taken this group of clones
this batch
but they've they're telling like the
most traditional star wars stuff like
crosshair
someone essentially who was once good
turning to the dark side and they want
to bring him back
familial tie of like no yeah just come
back
you know we can save you we can all make
this work
yeah today i i feel like this the show i
actually saw on twitter that it was uh
trending
um today i mean we shoot these on
fridays we don't stay until midnight on
thursday to shoot them
but we we we uh i thought this was
trending and i didn't know anything
about it but i was like hey yay i'm
happy for the bad magic yeah
and rarely see it coach redding so
i'm hoping that over time this show like
they already announced for a season two
so they got a lot more
in store to uncover obviously this
obviously these guys are alive like they
have this devastating cliffhanger but
they're obviously going to live
that'd be a bad batch i'd be surprised
if even one of them died i'd be very
surprised
if even one person died i'll you start
the next episode
is dead i yeah you're weird it's yeah i
wouldn't expect it but at the same time
i could see it happening potentially
i could lose
[Laughter]
echo i guess but think about all these
been been through
nah i would say tech you lose tech
i could lose tech over echo that's fair
he's probably my
least favorite one okay because yeah i
know you've been rooting for him
they're all essential no they're all
essential
it's just i'm like i feel like echo can
adapt what tech does that's probably
true and he could probably
jack into technology that much more
directly too
so i mean echoes had a really let's
re-lose everyone
if i had to off one of them it would
movie tech it would be omega
this is the one i find not as h i'm not
gonna say he's not interesting i was not
as interested in him as i am the other
characters you don't like his glasses
sure he's fine but uh echo echo's have
the rough life you know
yeah he's got the whole body this
morning i think
yeah he's got that he has a rough life
separated for a long time
yeah so he deserves a chance to keep
yeah
his technical insight is very very
necessary yeah and omega getting a
chance to shine here too is great
yeah i really think they've done a great
job with omega like she i really view
her as a capable part of the team
that's what i was sitting here
appreciating this episode
yeah because they don't draw this
attention to it
other than like you shouldn't be here
they're after us you know
calls for the distress signal like
moments after
that it's been like it's like a minute i
didn't have a chance you really got
there i just got to the other room
um but i i trust in her enough and she
seems really capable
to handle business as well not that
she's like fully matured to the point
where she's
equal level with them on skill set but i
think it is cool how
the show was started off with her where
i'm like she's gonna become a nuisance
is she gonna become this annoying ass
kid that yeah this is like just
running off and getting into trouble we
gotta save her and she kind of was that
for a lot of plot stuff but i feel like
she has matured a lot
in ways that uh are seemingly more
subtle than i anticipated to the point
where i'm like oh they're not even
really calling it out but it's there
yeah so i really like it yeah
well what are your theories for what's
going to go down in the finale the
official finale
this is crazy stuff man but there were
the people from the scientists from
camino
in the mandalore because this takes
place bef after
revenge of the sith where mandalorian
takes place after return of the jedi
so there were those scientists yeah and
they
they show this camino facility is who
and they were wearing the camino patches
and they're
not that this is the only place where
they have cloning facilities
it just seems like the main hub maybe
it's like an intergalactic operation
paperclip thing where like you know once
the camino facility is dissolved they
just send the different researchers to
all over the galaxy to where they need
them and can do research for
other nefarious government deeds i will
say it is interesting to have a
character like crosshair
willingly choose to to be with the
empire but
it's all for this very personal rooted
basis of of uh
i know what i'm designed for and my
what my design is best suited for is
this purpose here
what the empire has in mind and what i
can play as a soldier here
so uh there's i guess the part that
makes it intrigues or something that
feels like traumatic about his
reasoning it feels human the way it gets
played because i think it it
to me it's somewhere in between those
lines of like the empire he seems to
have a purpose he believed in the cause
that they were always fighting for and
how that transitioned into the new
empire and also
then yeah the betrayal of you know
i thought we were brothers and we would
always be on the same page together and
so
yeah yeah i don't know to me it did seem
like i i bought it when he's like
i want to give you a chance you know i'm
going to take out all my guys here and
i'm going to really extend the branch to
show you how serious i am about
like i think that was was what it really
pulled it together was like
it wasn't just come on with me you know
let's let's go
have glory at the empire no okay fine
i'm gonna shoot all of you like he
really
throws down on like i want us to you
know fix this i want you to take the
chance i'm giving you i want
you know to reunite and you know move
forward with our grand purpose or
whatever
and so like that made it feel
nuanced on top of the whole like i was
my choice alone because it it's
takes the extra step not to make him
just evil now and like oh secretly he
was just super evil
it's like you know secretly he's he's
just bought into an ideology that's
poisonous
and that's a very real thing and you
know it's like not that these are you
know the most allegorical stories but
you know especially in you know the
metaphors of you know an imp
an empire like this you know that's
something that everybody has to deal
with when something like that arises you
know when the people around you can be
swayed by that and really have the
conviction
you know to walk away from family or
connections like that you know
yeah i've cut off a lot of my family due
to political beliefs
that's right i haven't i know other
people have
i go let me get you on camera
let me post this to my story
[Laughter]
i'm gonna tag you in it i think people
will get a big kick out of what you
gotta say
yeah you're gonna go viral you're gonna
be internet famous
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below
check us out for the finale last but not
least let's do a
daniel gallacher you know what i did
today i was like i think it's time to
shout out daniel gallacher but i don't
want to do all the normal stuff
so i stalked you on instagram and you
know what i found out
daniel gallacher is a cute looking
dude man and plus i imagine you with
this scottish accent
i would love to clone you and have a
bunch of different versions of you so i
could hear
different iterations of your accent but
all through the scope of you know
various sci-fi characters and whatnot
you're a traveled guy so you would be
like right at home
moving throughout the galaxy and whatnot
plus
you know like the core you you can
obviously have your medical expertise
but think of all the other possibilities
man you could have one of you that's
like super buff
you could have one of you it's like
really skinny but with a big head and
he's like super intelligent
you could have one that's like a a kid
you could have one that's a dog or
something like that
it would be awesome all right okay okay
got it why don't we shout out daniel
gallagher
today's going through the list all right
daniel gallagher